entassés dans des minibus ces Ukrainiens
arrivent depuis les territoires occupés
par la Russie tous ont parcouru un
couloir de plusieurs kilomètres le long
de la ligne de front des combats
trouvant à peine la force de transporter
les quelques affair qu'ils ont pu
récupérer avant de s'enfuir ils font
halte dans un refuge qui leur offre de
la nourriture et un abri dernière étape
avant de retrouver leur
famille ce sont mes racines en fait
c'est une petite patrie toute ma vie est
ici c'est cher à mon âme à mon cœur
c'est précieux pour
moi mes enfants et mes petits-enfants
m'attendent ils m'attendent je suis très
heureuse de rentrer chez moi ceux qui
choisissent cette route entre en Ukraine
via un point de passage nonoficiel un
omansland surnommé la zone grise entre
la région russe de belgorode et la
région ukrainienne de soumi plus de
15500 personnes sont passées par ce
refuge depuis son ouverture en mars
dernier un nombre qui ne cesse
d'augmenter depuis que les informations
se sont répandus concernant notre centre
de volontaire concernant le couloir le
nombre de personnes a augmenté chaque
mois nous avons donc maintenant deux
centres humanitaires un à la frontière
et un à
soumis de nouvelles lois dans les zones
occupées exigent que les résidents de
ces territoirees acquèent la citoyenneté
russe d'ici juillet
2024 s'ils ne le font pas ils risqueent
d'être envoyés dans des régions reculées
de
Russie